we've got another gamespot news update  for you to mark the occasion of Gears of  War Ultimate editions released today  designer behind the series Cliff  Bleszinski has shared some interesting  facts about its development on Twitter  here are some of our favorite hashtag  gear facts verbatim I did not say these  from Cliff Bleszinski anya originally  had huge boobs but i push back on p  whoever that is to make her less  cartoony ironic considering the guys we  had a laser gun plan but we decided for  vietnam like tech so i was cut you can  see it in an early image of marcus a lot  of gears ones inspiration came out of my  sadness from the failure of my first  marriage and a visit to London before I  pitched it to Microsoft I did a bunch of  push ups in the hotel and listen to  eminem's lose yourself because dude bro  as it turns out it's time for my push up  for the day so for the rest of the  hashtag gear facts head over to our  article on gamespot com thanks for  watching